so it was with some amusement that I saw
that Boris Johnson's latest policy
initiative which is these sobriety bands
or tags to try to combat alcohol-fueled
crime have been described by the prison
reform trust some time back actually
when they were first mooted as a
populist gimmick because I thought well
that's probably going to attract the
mayor more than put him off to be blunt
ultimately populism is all the is
central to the Boris brand if you like
and the water cannon that he wants to
bring in or that he says that he wants
to make available for use on the streets
of London is another example of that
over the summer but then of course
contrast that with the fact that the
biggest decision who's trying to make at
the moment which is whether or not to
run again as an MP is something that
he's trying to do very much under the
radar and you know what I think one
factor that you might be weighing is
that the platform of City Hall has been
incredibly effective for that particular
Boris brand of populist politics it
might be that if the Conservatives were
to win and he were to be given some sort
of humdrum government department it
would be less effective from that point
of view and I guess that's a sort of
thing that might be running through the
mayor's mind over the summer